mesdames si vous cherchez un nouveau
cabas pour cet été vous pourrez pousser
les portes de l'atelier de catherine
kabanov ce week-end à saint-cyr-l'ecole
la créatrice des sacs câble dean qui
vient de me rejoindre bonjour à vous
bonjour alors deux jours de portes
ouvertes pour découvrir un peu vos
productions justement qu'est ce qu'on va
y découvrir dans cet atelier et bien
vous allez découvrir des créations
locales donc à saint-cyr-l'ecole des
créations françaises puisque ce sont des
cabas qui ont le label origine france
garantie qui garantit justement une une
plus-value française de 60% au moins que
ce soit sur la main d'oeuvre ou sur les
textiles et les matières premières
vous aurez des découvrez vous allez
découvrir pardon des cabas et des
accessoires toujours utiles au quotidien
mais aussi avec beaucoup de couleurs
parce que le quotidien est un petit peu
sombre on va dire et on va attendre le
soleil qui va venir très rapidement je
pense qu'il va être très très chaud et
donc les dernières créations j'ai fait
par exemple ce sac
exactement qui est un sac isotherme en
compte aux dimensions bien spécifiques
pour des bouteilles pour aller en pique
nique est ici vous avez un cabas pour la
plage et ce sont des tissus cela
particulièrement qui sont hissés dans
les pyrénées orientales près de
perpignan et alors là je vois qu'il ya
beaucoup de votre spécialité c'est le
cabba exactement quel rôle vous voulez
donner à ce produit aujourd'hui ce
produit c'est de remplacer
d'une manière systématique les sacs
plastiques et l'utilisation des sacs
plastiques même s'ils sont normalement
interdits on ne rencontre encore
beaucoup et les commerçants nous les
grandes surfaces nous en fin de compte
les font payer alors autant aller faire
des courses du shopping avec des choses
esthétique et française alors vous
croyez que le cabba est encore à la mode
aujourd'hui on en voit peut-être pas
tout le temps dans les rues effet le sac
et le cabba est toujours pratique en à
son sac à main et aussi on a son sac
cabas ou non mais toutes ces petites
choses
que ce soit une bouteille d'eau une
barre énergétique notre journal notre
bouquin et c'est toujours à mon avis
assez utile voilà sinon je me serais pas
lancée vous parliez de l'été il y a des
couleurs qui vont ressortir dans vos
prochaines productions le jaune par
exemple je sais pas
orange et cet été et quand même tendance
et vous avez le rayer enfin le rayer
mais surtout le blanc et noir que l'on
rencontre beaucoup et donc je sais de en
effet deux fois par an était et hiver de
coller aux tendances sinon ça serait pas
très très adéquat mais voilà et alors il
ya des productions qui sont un peu
particulières je crois parce que vous
donner une seconde vie à certains tissus
voilà c'est surtout à certains
accessoires j'ai
trouvé une association sur paris qui
valorise tous les déchets industriels
sert les chutes de coupe par exemple de
ceinture en cuir ou des poignées en cuir
qui n'ont pas atteint leur niveau de
qualité requis et qui sont donc mis à la
poubelle cette association récupère
valorise émouvant
donc certains accessoires et que je
crois que vous en avez un voilà j'essaye
en fin de compte gens ça aide à la
création aussi essayer des choses qui
sont très jolis on je vais réfléchir et
essayer de les réintégrer donc vous avez
ici ce sont des lianes en cuir et des
chutes de coupe de ceinture qui fond
blanc ce
pour ce cabas faire les les les cours
sont emmenés doudou tous les jouets des
enfants quand on va chez chez les
grands-parents des choses très pratique
et alors c'est artisanal la plupart de
vos productions comment vous vous
organisez justement puisque vous avez
vous consacré à cette activité depuis
deux ans vous êtes tout seul je crois
rires là comment vous faites donc je
crée je fais des prototypes et lorsque
j'ai des produits comme le dernier celui
ci est celui ci également je fais appel
à des ateliers esat anciennement seat et
sur paris nice entre eux mêmes par le
travail voilà exactement ce sont des
handicapés qui peuvent qui sont qui
peuvent très bien coudray qui sont dans
des ateliers quinze vingts personnes qui
sont dirigés et vous avez un résultat
tout à fait correct voilà comment vous
est venue à la couture parce que votre
société vous l'avez ouverte vraiment
officiellement il ya deux ans que vous
et que faisiez-vous avant donc avant
j'étais sûr dans un circuit très
classique c'est-à-dire assistante de
direction dans un grand groupe et j'ai
eu besoin de changer de faire un métier
qui me plaît plus et j'avais des
compétences au niveau de la couture
d'une manière autodidacte puisque depuis
l'âge de 18 ans je sait coudre et que je
fais ma garde-robe puisque les rondes
ont beaucoup de mal à trouver des
comment des choses et une garde-robe
joli et coloré en dans le commerce
traditionnel
et alors ce week-end lors de cette porte
ouverte on va pouvoir acheter des
modèles uniques j'imagine puisque si
vous voulez fait 6 et artisanal il doit
y avoir peut-être des modèles à un deux
ou trois exemplaires exactement donc là
vous aurez vraiment porte ouverte je
vais commencer à faire mon installation
parvenant en sortant certains malins
n'arrête pas vous savez et voilà ce sac
là par exemple il est unique parce que
je n'ai je n'ai pas encore produit même
si je le reproduis ce qui me reste du
tissu comme ça il y aura un détail
différents voilà alors rendez vous donc
samedi entre 10h et 21h et dimanche 10h
14h aller saint-exupéry à saint cyr
l'école voilà tout à fait et vous pouvez
vous reliez aussi sur le mon site sur le
site h1 et sur une page facebook pour
avoir les coordonnées
de mon atelier très bien merci beaucoup
catherine est revenu nous voir avec vos
belles productions et donc rendez-vous
ce week-end pour les intéressés pour
essayer d'acheter des modèles sûrement
très unique c'est moi qui vous remercie
si vous souhaitez visiter les plus
belles villes du département du d'une
autre façon ne passait plus par les
visites de groupes et adressez vous à 8
heures ces personnes vous font découvrir
le patrimoine de la commune bénévolement
sofival a fait une visite avec l'un de
ses guides
joseph et un greeter ce terme qui vient
de l'anglais to greet accueillir désigne
un habitant qui fait visiter
bénévolement sa ville par
l'intermédiaire de l'office de tourisme
et mardi matin ce retraité du milieu
industriel était attendu par un couple
d'anglais et leurs amis versaillaise au
coeur
joseph fait partie du réseau de greeters
de la cité royale un réseau qui vient de
s'agrandir avec un cinquième bénévoles
recrutés et qui attire de plus en plus
de touristes il ya un beau mince par
rapport à l'année dernière là j'ai une
demande pour pour une
mamie et ses petits enfants qui veulent
découvrir versailles autrement avec des
anecdotes voilà surtout des couples des
étrangers pas mal et des français aussi
joseph même son petit groupe au marché
notre dame par la rue des deux portes
l'occasion de glisser une nouvelle
anecdote oignies quoi quand on
traversait à l'époque
il fallait faire attention aux habitants
qui jeter leurs ordures par les fenêtres
l'ambiance de la balade et décontracté
comme le veut la philosophie du concept
basé sur les changes amical plus que sur
des connaissances encyclopédiques
j'ai beaucoup d'amis que ça soit aux
états unis en angleterre en italie en
egypte en israël au brésil
et moi quand je vais chez eux ils ne
font visiter et moi quand ils viennent
ici j'ai leur faut visiter mafieux ou
les châteaux la question pour autant de
concurrencer les guides conférenciers
une charte précise l'activité du greeter
aucune rétribution financière ni pour
boire pas de visite avec un axe
patrimoniale le phénomène mondial des
greeter né aux états unis il ya près de
20 ans ont créé à paris lyon nantes et
versailles depuis 2010 il n'a pas encore
séduit l'office de tourisme de saint
quentin en yvelines pour découvrir
versailles il est indispensable de
remplir un questionnaire les visites
étant programmée selon les
disponibilités des greeters
on passe maintenant dans cette page
loisirs aux balades et randonnées que
nous allons pouvoir faire avec notamment
sylvie là où la directrice des vignes
tourisme qui m'a rejoint bonjour à vous
bonjour alors week-end
de la pentecôte qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir découvrir je sais qu'ils y
aillent vers les yvelines qui va
commencer justement avec toutes ces
randonnées qui sont proposés oui alors
effectivement il y avait re les yvelines
dont c'est la première édition qui
commence demain donc on croise les
doigts pour qu'il fasse beau parce
qu'effectivement c'est une manifestation
qui concerne des randonnées que ce soit
des randonnées équestre pédestre ou
cyclo donc effectivement si le temps est
avec nous c'est encore mieux et ça sera
l'occasion à travers toutes ces
randonnées de découvrir que vraiment
nous avons un patrimoine
vers exceptionnel d'ouvert verte et les
yvelines et puis un patrimoine
historique également à ne pas manquer
puisque on veut bien le voir du monde
entier c'est le château de versailles
chez nous oui alors je crois qu'à la
base de loisirs 50 ans neeve il y aura
une randonnée un peu spéciale autour du
roi louis xiv oui alors effectivement à
la base de loisirs de saint quentin il
ya une randonnée autour de l'étang la
randonnée en question fait 10 km et on
partira sur les traces de louis xiv avec
des petites bornes qui sont avec des
fleurs de lys et quand on suivra ces
petites bornes et bien on se baladera au
gré de la vie de louis xiv autour de
l'étang donc en regardant des paysages
merveilleux et c'est ça tout l'objet de
notre événement l'histoire le patrimoine
et puis les paysages les paysages
justement je crois qu'on peut on peut
les découvrir avec la randonnée un autre
ex 1-1 en vexin c'est autre chose encore
donc c'est dans le parc naturel régional
du vexin français
c'est dans la forêt de verneuil où on
pourra randonnée avec des petits ânes
qui sont des animaux qui sont vraiment
espiègle et non pas uniquement têtus
comme on le dit d'habitude qui est très
attachant également donc on apprendra le
découvrir dans la forêt de verneuil à
l'occasion de cette randonnée qui a
organisé par l'association des guides du
vexin français et d'où vient enfin de
compte ce principe de verre les urines
pourquoi cette première édition cette
année alors en fait nous organisons
cette année trois événementiel pour
agrémenter les loisirs notamment des
yvelinois mais aussi des franciliens
sur des pratiques de loisirs qui sont
extrêmement prisé des français donc la
première pratique de loisirs que l'on va
la valoriser c'est au mois de mai c'est
vers les yvelines puis y en aura
d'autres le jardinage ou acceptant avec
paroles de jardiniers et une
manifestation sur la gastronomie et la
cuisine ce que la cuisine fait partie
des pratiques de loisirs des français
sans fin d'année donc voilà pourquoi on
va valoriser ces pratiques de loisirs
pour permettre de découvrir le
territoire autrement et le découvrir
autrement et ce qu il yad autres points
forts hormis et louis xiv cette base de
loisirs cabaye il ya beaucoup de
randonnées je crois c'est sur trois
week-ends en fait c'est ça oui oui c'est
sûr toi week-end alors il y en a surtout
les trois week-ends justement il ya une
randonnée parfaitement insolite auquel
on ne penserait pas parce que dans notre
programme n'a aussi des randonnées
insolite on a notamment une randonnée en
bateau un hors-bord qui par delà du
domaine de la corniche qui se situe à
rolle base donc sur les bords de seine
évidemment dans le nord ouest du
département on part sur ce hors-bord qui
s'appelle un hasard et puis là on va
découvrir les bords de seine qui ont
inspiré les impressionnistes et puis on
terminera cette balade par un petit
goûter au domaine de la corniche alors
comment fait-on je veux venir ce
week-end on s'inscrit sur place comment
ça se passe alors si on s'y prend un
petit peu de temps elle avance on
s'inscrit sur notre blog qui est dédié à
l'opération vers les yvelines vers
tirait les tirets yvelines point fr et
donc là on s'inscrit 6 et 6 et en
anticiper et puis si c'est au dernier
moment bien on essaye s'il n'y a pas un
quota minimum de personnes on arrive le
jour j et puis on peut participer quand
même mais s'il n'y a pas un quota
maximum évidemment très bien donc on
aura de quoi faire pendant l'e3 les les
week-ends qui suivent sur tout mais on a
notre randonnée phare effectivement qui
est extrêmement important puisque cette
randonnée fars elle sera dimanche là
c'est une randonnée cyclotouristique
organisé par nous on part de montfort et
sur le thème de la dégustation des
produits du terroir c'est une randonnée
cyclo de la journée qui fait 63 km on
peut la faire à la demie journée 28 km
on part de montfort on arrive au haras
des bréviaires où il ya une petite
dégustation de produits de la ferme la
récompense un petit peu c'est ça on a
bien on a bien pédaler on a bien mérité
on déjeune à la bergerie nationale
encore un endroit où on vend des
produits du terroir on passe par saint
léger ou là des petits produits encore
mets sucrés cette fois ci alors que le
matin c'était salé et on termine de
nouveau à montfort est là et on rentre
chez soi tout content d'avoir découvert
tout un tas de choses c'est ouvert à
tous parce que 63 km il faut les faire
en vélo quand même c'est pas alors c'est
pas commun c'est pour ça qu'il ya là la
faisabilité de faire que la demi journée
on a les accros les adeptes du vélo qui
font ça régulièrement qui vont
s'inscrire certainement à la journée et
puis ceux qui sont un peu plus un public
et un peu plus familial qu à moins
l'habitude et ils cela ils viendront que
qu'à partir de la demi journée au départ
de montfort toujours très bien merci
beaucoup si villa où et n'importe où ces
précisions et n'hésitez-pas donc du coup
ce week-end notamment si vous voulez
découvrir toutes les balades et les
randonnées de 2 vers les îles in merci
beaucoup d'énergie